screened out the pitfalls of wrong think
by Lawrence Fox first they came for the
statues Buzzle faulty or cancelled and
three spoiled millionaires turned on
their creator so it was with JK
Rowling's woke progeny Harry Potter it
would seem is deathly shallow Rupert
Grint looked for a moment like holding
firm that he too could lease comes to
the growing pressure to slip his golden
dagger between rolling shoulder blades
surely these Rich List regulars are
perfectly placed to say what they
actually think protected from the ever
tightening vice of censorship apparently
not fearing for their virtue or their
future or both the three children
rounded on their mother we must hope for
better from Neville Longbottom why to
have come to the conclusion that I may
never get an acting job again without
expressing correct opinions well this
probably isn't end of the world view it
is the cause of some sadness and anxiety
for me not least because I've always
loved my job and also because I have two
children who need dinner and clothes and
holiday once in a while in my job there
is a lot of waiting around and a lot of
banter and more serious conversations to
take place in onset until very recently
my views on life were met nicely with
good humor and if not always agreed with
always respectfully tolerated the
genesis of this rather bleak view of my
prospects came after my appearance on
question time where I voiced slightly
exasperatedly a heresy that I'm fairly
competent is held by a sizeable
proportion of the population the heresy
was that far from being hounded out by
the baying racists of this statistically
very tolerant and diverse country Megan
Markham might just might have left for
other reasons I haven't spent years
around actors are fairly common trait is
an enormous ego and the desire to be a
center of attention I include myself
very firmly in this bracket so with
little mental gymnastics involved I
wonder whether her departure might have
had something to do with her being
denied the limelight that she craved I'd
said this before on goggle box unknown a
batted an eyelid
that was six months earlier which amid
such blossoming clusters of the
pathogenic spread of the work religion
is an eternity my opinion was further
bolstered as I watched the brave and
amide prince slowly compost and droop
before our eyes into a bit of a salt
less Prince Hal more Prince hang on what
do I say next darling in this
progressive monoculture with his zealous
quest for faraway utopias I had
committed a grave sin I had used my
white privilege to berate and bully a
person of color as the ethnic minority
subcommittee of the actors union Equity
but it denounced him disgraceful came
the cries from the liberal liberals who
see race in every injustice and cry
fascism at anyone who doesn't view the
world from their same narrow an unstable
ledge of conformity the media had a
field day fortunately I'd have the sense
before my brain became so scrambled I
couldn't think too high myself a very
good lawyer something others without my
drilling financial privilege can ill
afford and equity was reminded politely
but firmly that the clue to which job
was in the touchless organization it
agreed to apologize and renew marae
Sydney for my troubles subsequently the
whole of the equity minority ethnic
members committee and then the newly
formed racial equality committee
resigned and as far as I can tell the
whole Union is on fairly wobbly ground
time passed I said about removing the
tar and the feathers and the left-wing
commentary at patters itself on the back
and moved on deliberately or not though
they'd missed the real story which was
more likely that Britain is an
overwhelmingly tolerant and welcoming
country one that people risk their lives
in attempting to reach or that Britain
is a place where racism and bigotry hide
in plain sight one of these stories
sells papers and the other one is true
anyway all this is by the by I use this
story to point out that even in the
smallest most of Arlen meaningless
situations identity politics can cause
ripples that turn into bigger and more
powerful waves when whipped up by the
winds of the outrage media
our silence that their corruption is
read by them as consent on the 25th of
May the world watched as a policeman
kneeled on a man's neck for almost nine
minutes killing him our jaws dropped in
horror and disgust something needed to
be done justice needed to be done and
seen to be done on that we were all
agreed black lives matter
three such powerful words words we can
all unite behind but was it that simple
a week later I got a text from a very
well-known young actor with a screen
shot of a tweeted line which read every
single human life is precious the end
can you explain this to me
I said the message my phone rang I
picked it up and I knew straight away
that my friend and I were not alone on
the call I heard a quiet shush in an
awkward pause the white noise on the
line changed to speak phone levels the
louder background the less intimate
voice that give these things away he
loves I want to really understand you
you know I mean I defend you as you know
and I really love you you're an actor
darling anything you love is in the
mirror but this this is really hard
which part of it I said conscience is
wrong what I said laws came the journey
menacing reply how can I defend you man
when you're saying [ __ ] like this [ __ ]
like what I said that every single human
life is precious which part of that is
problematic for you he's racist came the
reply
q deep sigh let me say at this point
that I firmly believe that most people
take on the bln mission statement at
face value and supported in kind I'm
aware that I'm not Black Knight no
concept of the lived experience of
anyone other than myself now where was I
yeah I asked my Chum what they saw when
they looked at the media coverage of
this whole story I asked for they'd
heard of David dawn a retired policeman
gunned down by a loser attempting to
steal a TV he once the writing began in
the news I'll swear they thought that
David Dawn's or also black life had been
murdered in cold blood yet George
Floyd's senseless killing dominated
every headline I asked for they thought
it was significant that the man who
gunned down David dawn when caught would
be charged with first-degree murder in
yet George Floyd's killer would be tried
for second-degree murder at best I asked
was this fair I asked whether the medium
I perhaps be complicit in Fanning the
flames of outrage whether George Floyd's
equally precious life was being used to
serve other most sinister objectives
there was a silence we ended the call
frost early and we haven't spoken since
my conclusion is that this tragic
situation has become part of another
narrative a series of stories wound
together to serve a broader societal aim
righteous global outrage at a cruel and
violent as morphed into a different
agenda similar things have happened with
other movements me to extinction
rebellion brexit even the coffered 19
pandemic the left rightly exposed great
chasms of inequality and hypocrisy in
society and then proceeded to throw
themselves like lemmings into that void
unable to pay their own edicts
desperately important causes have been
politicized to the point of
meaninglessness opportunities for action
hijacked swiftly by the cynical actors
no human being had failed to be appalled
by what happened to George Floyd we were
united in our outrage but what could
have become a moment for unity as
instead torn us apart all injustice
needs our collective and righteous anger
but the pursuit of that justice should
bring us together and not divide us not
social justice not climate justice not
black justice just
we must start with what unites us
beginning with trying to see the best in
people and though someone exploit our
good faith we should offer it
nevertheless we must be aware of a
biased media including our own state
broadcast to the BBC it is moved from
the Jeremy Bowen style show not tell
reportage of old - one that describes
protests that led to hospitalizations
and mass arrests as largely peaceful
some news suppliers have decided to
relativize and even encourage angry mob
tactics so here I am a white posh bloke
who loves his job who's worked hard to
be good at it facing uncertain future
all for the heinous sin of shaking my
fist at the ugly hypocritical and
inconsistent god of progressivism but
unhappily for some and my agent and my
bank manager mainly I will continue to
say what I believe to be true I'm not
always right and very often wrong but
unless we can accommodate multiple
understandings of the situation soon it
will all end with us abandoning words
and reason the tools given to us to heal
and come together in favour of the
simpler but far more terrifying tools of
engagement fists knives and guns it's
already happening and we should all be
concerned by it we cannot stand by in
silence words are the answer